Let's look at the solution
to our False Sharing Quiz.
We have two blocks, a block that has A,
B, C, and D in it, and
a block that has X, Y, Z, and W in it.
We're looking for which of these,
if any, have false sharing misses.
So let's first look at this one.
There is a read X and a write X.
The first will be a miss.
The second will also be a miss.
Both of these are compulsory misses.
X wasn't in C0's cache.
X wasn't in C1's cache, so
they have to be compulsory misses.
Read A here is also a compulsory miss.
This block wasn't in C2's cache.
Finally, C3 is writing to B.
This block wasn't in C3's cache so
this also a compulsory miss.
So in fact, this sequence has
no coherence misses whatsoever.
All of them are compulsory misses.
Now let's look here.
This is a compulsory miss for C0.
This is a compulsory miss for C1.
This is a compulsory miss for C2.
And this is a compulsory miss to C3.
So regardless,
whether we had coherence or
not, these four accesses
would be misses because
each of these caches needs to fetch
the block for the first time.
So there are no coherence
misses in this sequence either.
Now, let's look here.
C0 reads X.
C1 writes to X.
This invalidates X in C0.
This invalidation needs to happen
in order for X to be written in C1.
C2 now writes to W.
That invalidates the data in C1's cache.
The data in C0's cache was already
invalidated at that point.
When C0 tries to read X, the reason
it doesn't have the data in its cache
is because C1 invalidated it, and
C1 was accessing the same word.
So this is an example of true sharing.
We got invalidated because somebody
was trying to write the same word
that we were accessing.
So this is actually a sequence
of three compulsory misses,
followed by a true
sharing coherence miss.
So in this sequence there is
also no false sharing, so
none of these should have been selected.